return to the classroom also means the
return of public school transportation
madison kimbrough is in front of dondera
elementary school tonight
with the latest on what the district
plans to do to keep our bus systems
moving safely
for both drivers and especially students
yes while so many are focused on safety
within the classroom it's also important
to be aware of our children and driver
safety on the roadways too
in a scheduled press conference this
week school leaders came together to
talk about kids returning back to the
classroom tomorrow
and what that means for their safety in
regards to transportation
while it's been almost a year since ccsd
students have used the bus system
superintendent jarrah made a point to
address the plans in place
once they hop on board again we will be
operating 1600 bus routes
across the valley drivers will load the
bus from the back
to the front and unload from the front
to the back
each student will sit in the next
available seat and follow
seat markings to ensure that our kids
are practicing social distancing
while on the buses another thing
students and drivers need to be aware of
are crosswalks with kids now walking to
and from school
it's important for drivers to slow down
and for walkers to be vigilant of their
surroundings
that means keep your eyes up and not on
your phone while crossing the street
and buses will also be thoroughly
cleaned after each use
face coverings are required and hand
sanitizer will be provided to students
and drivers as they get on and off the
bus
reporting at don darrow elementary
school madison kimbrough
8 news now